in frankfurt am main bin ich jetzt
verbunden mit dr martin stürmer virologe
und laborleiter am md labor im dortigen
frankfurt am main ich grüße sie zum
phönix tagesgespräch hätte der stürmer
wenn wir schauen dass wir haben 27
dezember 2020 angefangen haben in
deutschland zu impfen
dann könnten wir uns jetzt nach sechs
wochen so was ähnliches wie eine kleine
zwischenbilanz erlauben
wie stehen wir da in deutschland ja was
das impfen angeht aber recht zögerlich
begonnen das liegt zum teil daran dass
wir uns die am schwersten zugänglichen
teil der bevölkerung als erstes
ausgesucht haben die ihre patienten die
über 80 cent oder in alten und
pflegeheimen verbringen ihre zeit
verbringen
und wir haben das problem dass dem
hersteller nicht in der form geliefert
haben wie wir sie aktuell uns gewünscht
haben und auch bestellt haben und das
macht das ganze etwas holprig ich bin
aber optimistisch dass wir den nächsten
wochen deutlich mehr gas geben können
es hat ja vorher eine relativ langen
vorlauf begeben man muss generell
konzedieren dass die impfstoffe sehr
schnell entwickelt wurden aber es hat
eine relativ lange debatte gegeben über
die richtige strategie die ja sozusagen
im kontext von ethikrat
robert-koch-institut bundesregierung
dann entstanden ist inwieweit hat die
sich aus ihrer einschätzung bewährt am
anfang war das sicherlich richtig so in
der form zu sagen wir erst mal dient
menschen die das größte risiko haben hat
für einen schweren oder sogar tödlichen
verlauf kann jetzt haben wir so ein
bisschen das problem dass der dritte
impfstoff der astra zenica impfstoff für
die ältere bevölkerung nicht empfohlen
wird insofern macht es jetzt auch meiner
meinung nach sind etwas breiter sich
aufzustellen den biotech und moderner im
stehen weiter für die ältere bevölkerung
zu reservieren und jetzt eben vermehrt
jüngere menschen zu impfen und da kann
ich mir durchaus vorstellen gerade in
der debatte die er jetzt schon läuft was
eröffnung angeht vielleicht noch mal
nachzudenken richtung lehrer richtung
kindergärtner da mal ein bisschen die
perspektive zu erweitern was sie im
strategien geht das jetzt machen sie das
stichwort priorisierung auf in der tat
laufen da aus verschiedenen
richtungen städtetag aber auch die
bundesbildungsministerin sagt also
lehrer erzieher nach vorne
sie würden das begrüßen wenn so eine
priorisierung geändert würde
ja ich denke wenn wir uns jetzt die
letzten wochen und monate vor augen
führen auch den ersten lockdown haben
letztendlich die kinder am meisten
darunter gelitten unter den maßnahmen
und auch die betreuenden eltern
die hatten es nicht leicht und dass wenn
wir über lockerungen überhaupt reden und
diskutieren gehört es da für mich auch
ganz nach vorne über schulen
kindergärten zu reden jetzt nicht drei
aus biologischer sicht sondern eben aus
der gesamtsicht und um den
größtmöglichen schutz eben für unsere
kleinsten klein zu gewährleisten fände
ich es nicht verkehrt zumindest über
dieses thema impfen für die erzieher
nachzudenken
reden wir noch ein bisschen über das ins
management auch da hat es durchaus
verschiedene sun kritik gegeben der
doktor stürmer das hat natürlich
durchaus auch zu tun mit der knappheit
der ressourcen am anfang und auch mit
den lieferschwierigkeiten die die
verschiedenen firmen erst nach und nach
auch eingestanden haben
jetzt gibt es da so eine neue linie und
empfehlung mich würde interessieren wie
sie das bewerten alle dosen sofort für
impfen also nicht sozusagen strategie 1
anwenden zu sagen ich halte auch immer
die zweite dosis für den patienten iks
oder y vor
macht das sinn alles sofort ran an die
menschen ich werde da sehr vorsichtig
klar wir haben einen gewissen spanne
zwischen der ersten und der zweiten
impfung das haben die studiendaten
gezeigt dass man beim bauerntag im
schlaf zb 42 tage zwischen erst und der
zweiten dosis haben kann und beim astra
zenica impfstoff scheinende ja sogar die
zwölf wochen die deutlich bessere
ergebnisse zu erzielen
aber das problem bezahlen wenn wir jetzt
erstmal bild doch los informale dosen
sind weg und dann kommen wir wieder in
einen lieferengpass team können uns die
firma offensichtlich nicht garantieren
die die sicherheit alle dosen wirklich
zu bekommen dann stehen wir da und haben
personen geimpft die haben dann zwar
einen gewissen schutz
aber nicht den den wir haben wollen und
das halte ich für bedenklich so wäre ich
damals wird vorsichtig lassen sie uns
zum schluss noch in zwei punkten ein
letztes kapitel aufmachen
stichwort mutationen dann müssen wir
beginnen bei der sequenzierung also wenn
wir irgendwo wirklich schlecht dastehen
dann offenbar da ich hab meine zahl
gelesen
letzten jahr 2020 gesamt haben wir
irgendwas im unteren vierstelligen
bereich an proben überhaupt nur
sequenziert wo stehen wir denn jetzt
haben wir jetzt unsere lektion gelernt
ja wir haben sicherlich da deutlich
nachholbedarf gehabt da gebe ich ihnen
vollkommen recht das war ungenügend und
jetzt haben wir gas gegeben das ist ja
seit drei wochen die neue verordnung in
kraft und dass wir als labore
verpflichtet sind ein teil unserer probe
zu sequenzieren bz weise anlagen
sequenzieller bürger weiterzugeben ich
denke werden jetzt ein sehr guten
überblick bekommen
das problem wird sein dass wir keine
richtige nulllinie haben wir können
jetzt die dynamik und noch gar nicht
abschätzen am ende deutliche zunahme an
infektionsketten durch die mutter hatte
oder liegt das einfach nur daran dass
wir vier messen
ich denke es ist jetzt von beidem etwas
wir werden deutlich mehr mutation um
varianten sehen in deutschland in der
tat sind der verschiedene zahlen auf dem
markt gestern letzten freitag gab es
eine von sechs prozent britischen virus
mutation auf jeden fall gibt es eine
große unsicherheit was die wirksamkeit
der impfstoffe angeht angesichts dieser
mutation können sie da noch einen
schluss einschätzung geben bitte bei den
m rna impfstoffen sieht es noch recht
gut aus da haben wir daten dass die auch
bei britischen und den anderen varianten
noch gut funktioniert bei den vektor
impfstoffen also astra zenica und und
sieht es nicht mehr ganz so gut aus da
müssen wir natürlich noch ein bisschen
abwarten
die gute nachricht ist dass einige
firmen auch schon auf die nächste
generation der impfstoffe bauen
sowohl der moderne als auch kia weg
jedoch nicht zugelassen sind haben schon
angekündigt entsprechende modifikationen
bereitzustellen
dr martin stürner virologe am md labor
frankfurt am main ganz herzlichen dank
für ihre einschätzung in phoenix
tagesgespräch danke dass sie sehr gern